what's required in part 2 okay so now
the algebra starts to roll out okay
think this is a if you have if you can't
recognize the format by the way this is
an HSE question okay
part one platoon clutter they haven't
told you but you should be cooing into
the fact that they're building their
building I don't doubt it's a good
conversation it's just really loud it's
your voice that I can hear okay now so I
look at par one and I think oh how am I
gonna use part one to do part two what
did you see yeah show me something
anything that's fine good yeah so you
guys say proportion or in the same ratio
I'm going to say so I've got a dying of
a dive like LaMarca um I'm gonna go Amy
on AC equals AC or ad that's the Perry
that I've chosen
okay the way that I would say it is
corresponding sides in similar triangles
are in proportion by the way in case you
hadn't worked it out already or haven't
been you know experienced the other side
of this this here this here is a crucial
thing in being clear all the time
there's a hallmark on this reason okay
so let's skip on it right that's that so
now I can fit in because I got all of
these labeled in terms of distances
right so I'm getting this
okay and once you've got that nailed
down
it's algebraically trivial you just have
to cross multiply and factorize I
believe we just need that is that right
yes
as for quite well actually I think that
was all we did it right I think that was
sufficient okay now what you have to do
is look at them as you go to the next
part and think why is that floating out
in the middle of nowhere
like this doesn't seem to lead anywhere
it's like nothing that much of a
profound
step forward right so when you look at
part three that give you a result right
a harder version of part three would be
find an expression for y in terms of a
and theta but they really want you to
get part three so they tell you what it
is right what clues are there in the
answer that give you a nudge
what direction you should go in theaters
okay
so cosine therefore cosine rule right
you've got angles and sides related in
non right angle triangle clearly I'm
going for close so I'm gonna go what's
my first line okay oh here we go
so I've got this form a squared plus
yeah it's what I had for my first line
yes okay now when you look at this this
is just using the cosine rule in an
appropriate training wall okay look at
what you try to prove and look at this
what's the culprit here that's standing
out and should be there yes the x
squared which you just proved was this
in terms of a turn wise okay so that's
why this just slots in from the previous
part that's right
okay so that's why I keep I keep asking
what clues are there in the restaurant
right you losing a square there and
there okay what am I trying to get I'm
trying to make why the subject right so
I guess I'm going to divide through by a
which leaves me with a minus a cos theta
and then I just factorize okay
now pause he is the most fun part and
most of you didn't get there so I won't
spoil it for you right away look at it
really carefully deduce this just seems
to come out of nowhere right that why
this guy is less than or equal to 3/8
now it's really hard to make this
transition that's why it's um it's the
end of question ten I think you have an
equation and you have to transition you
have to apply some serious logic to get
for an equation to it in equality okay
now you look at this thing right which
part of this do you think is the best
candidate to apply it in equality to
missing that guy in fact it has to be
this guy because a is some cluster of
some kind right like we don't know
anything about it okay and it's gonna
appear in the answer so here's how I
begin cos theta tell me an inequality
about cos theta
is less than or equal to one
good so I have this okay now I don't I
don't know yet which part of this will
be useful to me but I'm about to find
out
I just know that this is true this is a
starting point I can play logic to this
and I get to their result okay it
happens I don't have a cos theta here by
itself I have a 2 cos theta so I'm gonna
do this right we seen this before right
when we were mucking around domain and
range you see this before okay now two
cos theta I actually have two cos theta
I actually have minus 2 cos theta now
just watch out because you're chucking
this minus sign in here right everything
changes around okay
ah but nothing really changes and you
can see why can't you right what's the
difference between this function and
this function the answer is to cross
here so there's that right there's two
cos theta and then here's minus 2 cos
theta I missed but you get the idea
anyway
ok now the range is the same it's still
between -2 and 2 you with me so when I
have a look at this right look at this I
want to be a life span right I want to
be less than so which part of this is
actually going to be useful to me I'm
thinking it's a it's this part of it
here right now if that's not immediately
clear to you stay with me you'll see
what happens if you try the other side
right so I'm gonna write this with the
correct subject in the current spot do
you happy with that
yeah now I don't just have minus 2 cos
theta I have 1 minus 2 cos theta so I
need to add 1 to both sides to get that
oh look it's a 3 you see that
oh but wait I don't just have a 1-mile
you sicken me yet right I have an a
times 1 minus 2 cos theta so I have to
take this thing and I have to multiply
both sides by a by the way I can totally
do that and not change around with the
inequality why because a is a lake so a
is positive right no principles violated
oh but wait look at that left-hand side
I believe I recognize him